grand theft auto 5 has wrapped up its  Valentine's festivities in GTA online  but Rockstar still has plenty of tricks  up its sleeve from today februari 19th  through most of next week you can enjoy  lots of bonuses in GTA's multiplayer  mode it's called friends in high places  week and there's a lot to check out each  day you can get a mission from a  different GTA character like Trevor or  Lester finish it and you'll earn  yourself double cash and RP and right  after the event ends you can get double  the rewards from all contact missions on  thursday the twenty fifth and as usual  ammunation is holding a big sale stop in  for fifty percent off certain ammo types  and twenty-five percent off grenades and  sticky bombs we're all still waiting for  single-player DLC but rockstar is  offering no shortage of content for GTA  online if we do hear anything about that  expansion you'll hear about it on  gamespot and for all the GTA news you  need you're already in the right place  you